laurent duc directeur général de l'hôtel
des gratte-ciel et président de la
branche professionnelle et hôtellerie
française de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors d'abord cette
annonce de bruno le maire c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous je suppose le
maintien donc de l'aide
c'est une nécessité alors c'est une
annonce parce qu'il avait dû me monsieur
le maire avait promis qu'il n'y aurait
pas de tarés sec et qu' il
il avait dû finir un maintien des aides
pour nos métiers qui sont durablement
touchée je rappelle que on appelle un
retour d'un trafic aérien homogène en
il faut bien penser quand même que la
destination france elle attend des
touristes étrangers qu'elle n'aura pas
cet été et qu'elle n'aura pas sans cette
indemnisation est ce que rouvrir
uniquement les terrasses aurait été
rentable alors sérieusement pas rentable
parce qu'en plus on a fait alors nous on
a on allait demander à un calendrier ils
en ont disposé ce calendrier déjà il est
un peu surprenant et je reviens dessus
après et puis une terrasse s'il pleut
vous pouvez pas faire entrer les clients
à l'intérieur donc ça va devenir un peu
compliquée s'ils s'en plaigne le repas
et qui ya l inverse qui peut durer 10
minutes
et bien qu est ce qu ont fait les
clients quoi on le laisse sous les
parasols
on leur interdit de rentrer dans notre
restaurant parce que il n'ya que la
terrasse qui soit ouverte ou cette
question on m'a pas répondu à ses
questions
alors évidemment ça va durer que 15
jours ou dijon puisque le 9 juin les
restaurants seront ouvrait ouvert avec
une jauge à 50%
si la pandémie il n'est pas plus plus
agressive et si on a réussi à juguler
entre vaccins et traitements les gens
mais dans le même temps on a vrai on a
un vrai souci d flottation donc 30% à
peu près c'est la terrasse représente 30
concert du chiffre d'affaires une vague
idée distance etc
ça nous permettra pas de faire
comprendre tout le personnel déjà
voilà quoi c'est un peu compliqué il ya
des gens je pense qu'ils vont choisir de
même pour l intéresse il va falloir
attendre le 9 juin pour une réouverture
à des restaurants ç'aurait été possible
d'avancer le calendrier
à vous entendre alors d'abord huile je
pense que j'ai trouvée complètement
arbitraire d'ouvrir les régions dès
aujourd'hui et le tran le déplacement
interrégionale et en contrepartie de ne
pas ouvrir une offre parce que les gens
vont partir en week-end le week-end
prochain et et le jeudi de l'ascension
ils vont partir dans le midi en
aquitaine en bretagne et ils vont avoir
une offre 2 0 au bout donc ça va être
encore une fois du n'importe quoi que
les gens vont être sur les uns sur les
autres par les espaces publics 117-110
sensation ne fait confiance aux
professionnels pour organiser la
distanciation sociale et le maintien
d'un certaines notes dans la
consommation
là les gens ils vont boire d'alcool
stands et il y aura arrivée vers 17
sauvage il va y avoir des gens dans les
parcs sur les plages
un jeu vous ajustez pas la peine que je
fasse un exemple voyez bien ce qui se
passe en ce moment
et s'agissant du protocole sanitaire
vous êtes prêts alors le protocole
sanitaire il avait été établi avant
premier confinement se rajouterait à ce
protocole sanitaire actuaires que de que
les gens pourraient l'utiliser les le
contour de tout ça n'est pas fixée dans
notre capacité à le faire appliquer de
danse qu'on attende de ce passeport vert
entre guillemets que l'europe semble
initié au type de la destination
parallèlement nos personnels des trains
propriétaire à la vaccination
ça aussi ça fait partie des points qui
sont complètement complètement
nous on serait la seule profession
quitte à eric des gens sans masse qui
les ont pas été vaccinés c'est quand
même c'est quand même assez je pense
qu'on réfléchisse à l'envers je suis je
salue le travail de nos éboueurs mais
qu'il ne rencontre personne et des
maçons qui pose des moellons mai en
présence de public sans masque donc je
pense que c'est personnel à eux
devraient être au rire nos personnels
doivent être prioritaires avec six
nations pour rassurer les clients
rassurer la destination
deux chambres dans les hôtels n'ont
jamais arrêté de travailler et elle
rentre dans des chambres des gens et les
rues vides ont séjourné et laurent
laidez carmaux peut-être pour les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs qui ne
disposent pas d'une terrasse dans ce cas
là c'est la fermeture encore c'est mon
ne plaît mais c'est l'aide qui a été
mise en place à hauteur de l'inconscient
du chiffre d'affaires qui au demeurant à
l'étude des deux va pas se voiler la
face à beaucoup de restaurateurs au
dessus et ont pu et continue de pouvoir
exister grâce à cette aide sera le
problème à résoudre à l'entrée de la
réouverture du paiement des congés payés
quand vous n'avez pas été comme les
boîtes de nuit 14 mois fermé et les bars
restaurants neuf mois eh bien vous devez
tous les congés payés à ces gens là si
on leur donne boutabout y aura pas de
personnel cet été un mot sur la gratuité
des terrasses parce que cela fait débat
et dans le jdd
anne hidalgo la maire de paris a annoncé
que les terrasse éphémère restaurer
gratuite jusqu'à la fin de l'été au
moins dans la capitale qu'en est-il à à
lyon et villeurbanne et est-ce qu'il
faut prolonger ce principe de terrasse
éphémère
alors mes collègues lyonnais et
successeur d'ailleurs puisque j'étais
président du rhône ont entretenu un vrai
dialogue avec la mairie de lyon et lille
mairie de la métropole pour pouvoir
avoir des extensions de terrasses et
pour pouvoir justement exercé le plus
vite possible dans des conditions de
laisser respectable et des conditions
d'utilisation financière 0 jusqu'à la
fin de l'année je pense si en tout état
de cause jusqu'à la fin de l'été et des
terrasses provisoire voire même pour
pouvoir maintenir des terrasses tout
aller sur des places de stationnement
c'est une grande avancée à lyon merci
beaucoup à vous l'orangé d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de la branche
professionnelle hôtellerie française de
l'umih et beau courage à vous remercie